enfin pourrait-on dire les ministres de
l'agriculture de l'union européenne sont
d'accord et satisfait après deux ans de
discussions ils se sont entendus sur la
nouvelle politique agricole commune la
pac qui soutient la filière et son
développement dans l'union européenne
cela ne surprendra personne cette
réforme s'est parée de vert désormais
pour percevoir la moindre aide les
agriculteurs devront se plier à de
nouvelles règles environnementales de
base chaque état consacrera ainsi 20% de
ses paiements directs de la pac aux
échos régime un système qui versent des
primes aux agriculteurs s'engageant sur
des programmes environnementaux plus
exigeants le bio par exemple
l'agroforesterie
mais chaque pays aura toute latitude
pour définir son propre programme son
plan stratégique national
en tout la pac sera doté d'un budget de
387 milliards d'euros sur sept ans plus
de 62 milliards seront reversés à la
france qui craignait d'en perdre une
partie peut-être est-ce pour cela que le
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation julien de normandie s'est
félicité de cette nouvelle politique
agricole commune
après de nombreuses heures de
discussions la nouvelle pac vient d'être
défini par le conseil des ministres de
l'agriculture des mesures
environnementales pour tous les états
une compétition plus juste au sein du
marché commun c'était une attente forte
de la france
mais pour certains la pax a fait pschitt
cette mère europe ecologie les verts de
grandes métropoles françaises et le
président de lyon métropole ont lancé un
appel en faveur d'une autre pack
quant aux principales ong
environnementales comme le bureau
européen de l'environnement elles
déplorent son manque d'ambition
écologique
malgré les intentions affichées elle
redoute au contraire une concurrence
accrue entre états ou encore le
renforcement de l'agro-industrie au
détriment des petites exploitations
selon les ong
cette nouvelle pac ne pourra permettre
de respecter les engagements
environnementaux de l'union européenne à
savoir 50% de pesticides en moins d'ici
2030 et 25% d'agriculture biologique
pour ses élus et ses ong la réforme ne
permettrait pas de venir à bout des
problèmes endémiques des agriculteurs en
france un quart d'entre eux vivent en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
on assiste chaque semaine à la
disparition de 200 fermes au titre des
disparitions déplore d'ailleurs aussi
celle des espèces animales la politique
agricole commune est aussi contestée par
l'eurodéputé socialiste français
vic andrieu qui en était pourtant le
rapporteur d'un des volets à la voie
d'un côté onirique buteur qui personnes
des sommes considérables voilà et de
l'autre côté les mesures que l'on donne
pour les petits agriculteurs sont
plafonnées dans ce qui est sur la table
à 1250 euros par an pendant la
proposition par agriculteur ce qui
m'apparaît totalement inconvenant
mais c'est le choix d'un modèle agricole
donc moi je pense qu'il faut aller la
vidéo de proximité développer sur
l'appel initié puis cours et radio la
qualité alimentaire
c'est ce vendredi 23 octobre que le
parlement européen doit discuter voter
ces nouvelles règles et mettre en place
des garde-fous et peut-être éviter que
cette pac déjà très contesté ne fasse un
flop